dans un monde où tout se ressemble c'est
vachement bien de voir des propositions
qui sont différentes aujourd'hui je vais
donc vous parler d'un smartphone qui est
différent tous les smartphones
aujourd'hui il ya quasiment tous se
ressemblent beaucoup beaucoup en tout
cas les design ressemble de plus en plus
les deux sont quasiment tous les mêmes
les modules photo se rapprochent les uns
des autres et c'est vrai que
l'uniformité qu'à force on en souffre un
peu et peut-être à la casquette l'année
dernière thé scène m'avait déjà envoyé
un smartphone c'est celui là c'est le
disent prendre dix projets en ai pas
parlé j'aurais peut-être pu vous en
parler mais vous en ai pas parlé qui est
dans mes placards depuis un petit moment
et déjà je le trouvais différent parce
que il y avait ce module photo l'a
complètement plat vous pouvez les poser
à plat il est complètement stabilisé
donc ça c'est un truc qui me plaisait
beaucoup j'avais trouvé ça vraiment
différent d'un point de vue esthétique
et sans avait vachement plus tcl est
revenu cette année en faisant cas
monsieur gros vote représentait nouveau
téléphone alors les ont pas fait cette
voie c'est ma façon à moi de changer un
peu les petites boîtes recevront les
petites voix comme ça ça change un peu
et 30 du coup je me suis dit on va aller
voir ce qu'il fait et celle en 2021 et
ça m'a caressé ça m'intéressait pourquoi
parce qu'il ya une gamme
je vais pas vous parler de la gamme g
pas vous présenter la gamme je vous
parlais surtout d'un smartphone c'est
celui là c'est le tsl c'est le vin
procès le flagship c'est le plus haut de
gamme et le plus gamme il est
intéressant parce que justement on
retrouve cette idée
l'appareil photo qui ne dépasse pas qui
est complètement intégré vous pouvez
poser sur une table ne va pas bouger
donc ça c'est très très rare et ton coup
ça m'intéresse à simple et alors je vais
vous parler par extension de celui là
c'est le vin elle plus je lis parce que
les noms seront très compliqués chez les
fabricants de smartphones j'ai
l'impression qu'un espèce de consensus
pour se dire on va faire des noms
compliqués comme ça personne n'y
comprend rien ça sera super alors tu
essaies elle fabrique benevides amants
des smartphones il fabrique des
téléviseurs vert très très bon niveau
des téléviseurs et ils ont également des
solutions audio alors on la passe par
exemple du roi passe par les télés on va
se parler de smartphones va se passer de
deux smartphones
on va se parler du tcl du vin prouva se
pare du tc du vin et le plus plus du vin
trop que du vin est plus qu on va
regarder s'ils sont cool on va regarder
à quoi ressemble déjà ce qui est bien
vous allez voir c'est design le design
change et ça ça me plaît
[Musique]
il y en a ailleurs diana y en a il y en
a beaucoup au centre n 12 qui nous
intéresse c'est ce modèle là ce modèle
là ça c'est le vin pro ça c'est le vin
elle plus regardées sont mignons alors
déjà ce que j'aime beaucoup au niveau du
design je vous dis tout de suite c'est
ce côté plat la regarder pouvait le
poser comme ça c'est un des rares
téléphones qui ne bouge pas il n'a pas
de déséquilibre et ça c'est du
effectivement et bien grâce à cette
partie là qui est complètement plate
pour le coup c'est le module où vous
allez avoir regardé sais pas si vous
avez gallois le module ici au niveau des
flash led qui va avoir un peu de relief
mais tellement petit qu'on le sent à
peine sous le doigt donc ça c'est
vachement bien
alors vous me direz qu'est ce que ça
change pas ça change que si vous prenez
le vin il plus il va bouger un peu plus
le vin et le plus mais celui-là le vin
pro et même le modèle qu'on avait une
dernière sert le disent pro bah ça ne
bougeait pas la fabrication est très
très très très très mal y est ça apporte
vraiment quelque chose de design c'est
très différent voyez pour un smartphone
à 550 euros
on va compter sur un smartphone a tout
de suite à 269 euros avec le vent et le
plus
eh bien ça on ne l'a pas on a quand même
un petit module caméra qui ressort
davantage
on va regarder si pour autant en termes
de photos c'est intéressant ou pas parce
que abord un dingue comme ça ça
fonctionne mais si le résultat derrière
n'est pas satisfaisant à bien cette sa
global moi pas grand chose alors avant
de regarder ça on sable sur du côté du
design vous avez si une prise jack vous
avez ici de l'infrarouge donc ça c'est
plutôt pas mal
on va retrouver ici le bouton de volume
le bouton pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre
ok de la recharge en usb c'est votre
lecteur de cartes signe ici plus de la
microsd et là vous avez un autre bouton
alors regardez ça c'est intéressant
john may 14 empreintes digitales pour
venir déverrouiller sa débrouille pas
trop mal à vous de bien enregistrer
votre votre empreinte
et puis vous avez hop là ici un petit
bouton qui est intéressant moi j'ai dit
une fois dessus et bien c'est pour la
photo
deux fois dessus up j'allume ma petite
lampe deux fois dessus je l'éteins et
puis un appui long vous appelez google
assistant coco google comment vas tu
merci absolument rien la différence que
je vais avoir vraiment entre ces deux
smartphones
là on est à 550 là on est à 2 169 c'est
l'épaisseur le vin elle plus est
beaucoup plus épais un peu plus massive
dans la main et la prise en main sera
beaucoup moins d'eau que lorsque je vais
prendre celui là tout de suite ça
laissera beaucoup plus agréable plus
confortable un peu plus loin un peu plus
profil est donc sage
tulisa y est je trouve vraiment bien
donc super bien réussi surtout différent
par rapport à ce que je peux retrouver
sur le marché donc là dessus très beau
boulot tcl au niveau de la photo vous le
voyez g4 capteur à l'arrière alors j'ai
un principal c'est un grand angle c'est
mon 48 mégapixels c'est mon capteur
principal d'avoir soutenu tra
grand-angle c1 16 mégapixels avec un
champ de vision de 123 degrés j'ai de la
macro en 5 mégapixels et puis j'avais
quatorze profondeur en 2 mégapixels et
puis j'ai une caméra de celle ci à
l'avant qui est planqué justice qui elle
est à 1,32 mégapixels donc voilà ok pas
pas grand chose de plus petite
différence que je vais avoir avec celui
là c'est que du 48 jabarin 64 au lieu du
16 sur l'ultra grand temps que j'avais à
1,8
j'aurais de la macro 2 mégapixels et
georges lautner profondeur on 2
mégapixels pris ma caméra de cette fille
si elle fera 16 mégapixels on commence
en des photos avec le vin pro regarder
la caméra principale le ciel
il est très bleu on en plein mois de
juillet enfin ciel bleu absolument
incroyable et pourtant il a l'air assez
blanc c'est assez bizarre le haut du
bâtiment et à peu trop cramé lorsque
j'ai zoomé que j'aime rapprocher bien
voyez là les détails au niveau des
fleurs marche pas et pourtant on est en
x 2 c'est un peu dommage je passe sur
lui très grand-angle
j'ai un espèce de bleu au niveau du ciel
qui une fois de plus c'est pas hyper
hyper naturel je suis pas hyper fan du
détail très honnêtement je connais
photos sont pas extraordinaires
là je me rapproche de quatre ans en
équivalent de 2 x 5 c'est pas ouf
et je me rapproche en faut 10 là on
oublie carrément mais voyez il ya toutes
ces photos là qui sont pas dingue dingue
je trouve ça un peu dommage toute la
gestion des lumières est pas très bonne
la gestion de votre ligne envoyer le
ciel est bleu le ciel est tout bleu et
on a l'impression qu'il ya des nuages
avec le ciel et blanc donc pour moi ce
n'est pas satisfaisant il reste vraiment
vraiment sur ma faim regardez là on est
sur l'ultra grand temps que c'est
complètement cramé à droite l'expo n'est
pas du tout bonnes même le bleu là sur
le grand angle et il est pas beau sur
l'ultra grand temps que c'est un espèce
de bleu qui bizarre en fait on est très
loin de la réalité et je trouve cela
frustrant sur un smartphone à 549 euros
d'obtenir ce résultat là je regardais la
macro pour trouver aussi le point c'est
assez difficile je suis déjà pas très
très grand fan de la macro mais là ça
n'a pas non plus convaincu
donc voilà on essaie différentes choses
voilà c'est pas ouf la caméra de cette
fille elle fait le taf se trouve un peu
terme mais bon elle fait tard je vous
emmène sur le vin et le plus qui est le
smartphone qui coûte moins cher et bien
je trouve que c'est mieux on a mieux le
ciel bleu pour le coup c'est c'est pas
cramé lui
un grand-angle est pas ouf non plus on
peut se rapprocher en x 2 x 4 au maximum
sur celui là ça ne posera moins de
problème mais pour le coup lui il voit
le ciel bleu là où l'autre nous le met
en blanc donc voilà pour moi c'est c'est
un point faible la photo qu'on va
retrouver sur ce smartphone alors aux
smartphones à 269 euros ça ne posera
aucun problème sur un smartphone à 549
euros
c'est tout de suite beaucoup plus
problématique bon la macro c'est pas
mieux me fait plus rien de bien
surprenant ici et là caméra selphy bon
c'est kif kif bourricot
ici j'ai un écran incurvé sur le pro et
ses trucs qui me plaît bien alors je
sais pas si vous aimez les écrans une
curieuse alors dites-le moi en bas en
commentaire moi j'aime bien ici écran
incurvé ici à écran plat alors le truc
que je vais regretter un tout petit peu
mais vraiment un petit peu histoire de
chipoter
c'est que je trouve que pour autant j'ai
eu une partie noire qui est quand même
assez grande aujourd'hui sur le haut et
sur le bas par rapport à ce que je peux
attendre un smartphone à ce prix là bas
c'est vraiment du poids des tas
d'histoires devenir chipoter mais ça me
dérange pas dans l'ensemble c'est
vraiment histoire de bien vous le
montrer ici écran incurvé c'est de la
molette full hd + 6,67 poussant plus
d'une techno qui est intéressante c'est
la techno nxt vision sans gros un moteur
graphique qui permettra d'améliorer
l'affichage au niveau de votre de votre
smartphone
on peut venir optimisé l'image optimiser
les jeux et les vidéos on monte jusqu'à
700 nits et puis ce ratio 29e surtout
c'est un écran qui est certifié lutter
contre la lumière bleue et de l'autre
côté on n'est pas du tout sûr
de l'amoled on est sur deux lits ps un
très grand classique écran plat full hd
+ également 6,67 pouces
de la même manière ce sont des grands
écrans tous les deux on a de la même
manière le nxt vision hockey ici on est
à 700 nits maximum ici on est à 500 dit
je les ai mis tous les dehors en plein
soleil on voit ça fonctionne
donc rassurez vous ça c'est cool ici
j'ai un taux de rafraîchissement n'ont
pas de 120 hertz non pas 80 diète mais
de 60 hertz ce que j'ai regretté ici
c'est que j'ai pas un écran 90 voire 120
hertz alors on se calme on les en milieu
de gamme le tarif c'est 549 euros ce
modèle professionnel donc on va dire et
à 549 euros aujourd'hui en 2021 on
s'attendrait à minima à voir en d'écran
avec un taux de rafraîchissement de 90
ans et ici c'est pas le cas je reste un
peu sur ma faim et ça m'embête jeunes
m'ont pas trop trop sur le multimédia
c'est la partie audio vous avez juste un
petit haut parleur mono qui se situe à
là aussi je reste sur ma faim
j'aurais espéré aller pourquoi pas
rester sur haut parleur mono ça je peux
complètement le comprend et une fois de
plus dans ce segment de prix ça me
paraîtrait normal mais j'aurais aimé
avoir une meilleure qualité ici je suis
sûre en sont quittes ray médium et
lorsque je le pousse pousse pousse et je
vais sur du médium qui va saturer un
peuple et ça me dérange j'aurais préféré
bien qu'en ayant un haut parleur mono
avoir respecte un poil plus large on y
arrive aujourd'hui sur l'audio on y
arrive au niveau des smartphones et
c'est un peu dommage alors à côté de ça
rassurez-vous vous avez ici une prise
jack donc vous pouvez bien branché un
petit casque si vous souhaitez donc ça
viendra peu corrigé là le problème
et vous avez en plus du bluetooth cinq
points donc si vous souhaitez appéré un
casque sans fil vous pour une fois de
plus ya des solutions
ça peut être la bonne combinaison mais
tel qu'il est là avec l'eau parleurs
c'est un petit peu frustrant autre point
qui est intéressant c'est ce qu'on va
retrouver sur le modèle professionnel au
niveau de la performance on a un
instinct dragonne ses 1 750 g pour
gaming c'est un processeur 5g c'est un
grand minimum aujourd'hui ans en 2021
sur le vin et le plus vous avez un sens
dragonne 662 broc le vin le plus on va
laisser un peu de côté
ici vous avez si giga de ram sur les
donneurs si giga de ram 256 go de
stockage extensible dans les deux cas
jusqu'à un terrain grâce à une carte
microsd
ça me va bien une fois de plus pour 550
euros jour espérer avoir un pépin un
processeur 1.2 plus performants parce
que et si vous regardez ce qu'on a en
face à la concurrence même sur des
modèles de l'année dernière je vous
prends et noter les cieux par exemple le
one + 8 alors le web peut citer il est
sorti en 2020 dans la deuxième partie de
2020 c'est pas le smartphone qui vient
de sortir mais mal
et où il a un processeur qui est
beaucoup plus performant que celui là
c'est le sang dragons 865 illégalement 5
g là il ya une config en 8 + 101 qui
tournait à 499 euros ça veut dire que
j'ai un smartphone qui est même si
l'année dernière va être plus performant
que ce smartphone là à 549 euros dont
moi je suis consommateur au moment de sa
mort fois je ne posais la question
j'aime bien est-ce que je vais prendre
ce smartphone l'acquis et de 2021 ou
alors est-ce que je vais aller sur un
smartphone de 2020 qui bien qu'étant un
peu plus anciens sera plus performant
nous coûtera un peu moins cher
that is the creation c'est un peu le
point un peu délicat à côté de ça le
syndrome 750g keita fait vraiment gain
d'affilée aurait peut-être eh bien non
je dirais pas tourné quasiment tous les
jeux du playstation aurait absolument
aucun problème ça ne marchera bien
s'attendre est là dessus pas de mauvaise
surprise
ça fait le taf à côté de ça parce que
j'ai pas tout appris par coeur vous avez
une batterie de 4500 milliampères heures
c'est une fois de plus un très grand
standard vous avez de la recharge rapide
18 watts et sur le modèle plus petit on
va l'appeler le plus petit vous avez une
batterie de 5000 militants paire eur 18
watts également en termes de recharges
et vous avez de la recharge sans fil
ces deux-là 15 watts et de la cuy ok
pourquoi pas 60 va bien je recharge de 0
à 50 % en 35 minutes c'est suffisamment
rapide ça me va bien alors l'autonomie
ça va dépendre une fois plus de vous va
dire une journée et demie une journée si
vous partez s'il vous allez beaucoup
dessus une journée une musique si vous
avez un peu plus tranquille deux jours
vous êtes mollo mollo on est dans les
standards
côté logiciel se tourne sur android 11
basé sur tes ciel que j'aime bien c'est
dans mon tiroir d'application tout et
classées par thématiques communication
multimédia utilitaire google système tcl
et si je veux venir planquer des
applications deux doigts du bas vers le
milieu hopla application confidentiel
j'en ai mis aucune
mais si par exemple j'en sais rien moi
je vais me dire que haas 29 et bien
c'est confidentiel
hop là je la joute g asphalte 9 ce qui
fait que lorsque je viens ici le
chercher au niveau de mes jeux et bien
je le vois plus et pour le récupérer je
viens là deux doigts je te s'appuyer
est-ce que c'est intéressant
why not en tout cas ça existe et c'est
plutôt pas mal alors après on a un petit
truc ici là vous venez planquer des
applications aux applications préférées
et après vous souhaitiez pourrait mettre
des contacts vous pouvez le mettre à y
venir mesurer voilà faut bien mesurer ce
que voulait chez vous pourquoi pas et
puis ensuite télécommande si ça vous
intéresse d'utiliser comme une
télécommande
je pense que pour moi une des fonctions
pour moi le plus intéressant ça va
vraiment être
les applications et les contacts assez
petit raccourci après on a les grands
basique 1 d'android 11 c'est assez
lisible ça fonctionne assez bien
c'est pas l'expérience logiciel que je
vais préférer mais malgré tout elle fait
le taff elle le fait plutôt bien
mais dans l'ensemble c'est plutôt
pratique allant le petit bémol c'est au
niveau de la partie photo choisie
surpris en fait parce que regarder
lorsque je mets comme ça que je fermais
photo là je suis enfin japy dessus une
fois ils passent directement en x 2 jeu
rapide sur une passe sur l'ultra grand
angle et jeu rapide sur ce point et
lorsque je vais venir monter alors là je
le sens ça vibre un peu je peux monter
jusqu'aux os x 10 mais c'est étrange ont
préféré la voir sur la partie de droite
soit plus simple en fait il faut le
faire avec soin la main gauche comme ça
je me préfère l avant avec le côté droit
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il faut le
faire avec demain et fois il ya un truc
est bizarre et si vous passez sur
l'autre modèle c'est encore différent
là pour le coup j'ai cette icône qui a
paru sur le côté alors japy dessus je
passe sur l'ultra grand temps que je
l'enlève je reviens sur mon grand temps
normal j'appuie la hobson néant x 2 ra
puis en faut quatre et là je suis en max
en x 4 je trouve que d'un point de vue
purement logicielle s'est pas
complètement génial comme ça c'est pas
hyper optimale puis vous avez vraiment
une différence entre les deux ce
smartphone ses smartphones d'ailleurs
ont tous les deux du nfc pour le témoin
dématérialisée ça c'est bien ce qu'ils
n'ont pas assez du wifi 6 alors pour le
vin est le plus élevé de jodoigne plus
saturés retenir pour le vin il plus
qu'on en ait pas c'est pas très grave
j'aurais bien aimé sur celui-là en avoir
deux indépendants dans le milieu de
gamme donc c'est pas extrêmement grave
on n'est pas sur un fact it donc bon
c'est pas très grave
par contre ici j'ai pas de certification
ip pour autant il est résistant à l'eau
et à la poussière on va éviter de le
mettre dans la piscine et le tremper
dans son verre de bière mais au delà de
saint cyr rencontre de l'eau ça devrait
aller
mais voyez c'est des petits points
d'état qui disent ah ah il lui manque
que ça et ça peut me faire un petit peu
râler à côté de ça on est quasiment ici
à 550 euros on à 549 euros ici je suis à
2 169 euros pour être extrêmement précis
j'en ai pour mon argent j'ai un bel
écran qui me semble bien calibré j'aime
bien ce côté incurvé j'aime beaucoup le
design avec ce côté caméra très très
plat je viens à regretter que ce
smartphone il soit pas meilleur en
termes de photos je viens regretté
l'audio qui est pas d'un goût dago pour
après c'est pas grave on vient la
plupart du temps écouter avec un casque
on n'écoute pas forcément que les haut
parleurs que vous avez là il ya eu
quelques petits points d'amélioration is
it est celle que je voudrais vraiment
voir la copie dans l'ensemble est assez
cohérente
à 550 euros maintenant moi en tant que
consommateur est ce que c'est un
smartphone que j'irai acheter
je suis pas convaincu je suis pas
convaincu non pas parce que la marque me
plaît pas eu non pas parce que le
produit n'est pas intéressant mais par
rapport à la concurrence parce que
tellement de choses je trouve que ce
smartphone là aujourd'hui tel qu'il est
présenté en 2021 manière me 2021 par
rapport à ce cas sur l'ensemble du
marché
il lui manque un petit quelque chose au
niveau de la photo c'est pas la
performance qui va me déranger
une fois que j'aurais aimé un peu plus
de performance est vraiment ce côté
photo à ça des usages plus important et
je trouve qu'il pèche un peu là dessus à
côté de ça c'est vraiment une marque
qu'on va suivre parce que je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant ce qu'ils font et
les propositions il essaye d'être
différent ils le sont déjà au niveau du
design ya des valeurs qui sont
différentes d'une façon un smartphone
reste un smartphone et je sais pas si
vous le savez tcl enough beaucoup au
niveau des écrans qui se paie donc
tesselles on en reparlera dans tous les
cas peut-être cette année probablement
2022 dans tous les cas tcl ses marques à
suivre elle est super intéressante on
reparlera de tessa leur parlera
probablement télé tcl les écrans tcl
c'est vraiment un truc pour me dire ce
que vous en pensez on va encore en
taclant vous le trouvez comment vous les
trouvez cpcl le vin elle plus et le vin
pro voilà on est tous à en bas en
commentaire vous avez déjà acheté un
produit de thé c'est au niveau des
smartphones peut-être de la télé ou
alors de l'audio et que ça j'ai encore
marqué ma tout ça on va en commentaire
quand on se retrouve très vite continuer
à parler des classes et l'été on descend
un petit peu tranquille tranquille et on
s'arme pour la rentrée croyez-moi
septembre pour ça va y aller fort des
bisous pour les soins vous prenez soin
de vous des vacances des bisous de la
moto
ciao on a besoin des vacances oui les
bidons